si le tout l'allier
distance à 0 monte à mourir parce que
c'est ma vie contre est très jeune très
très jeune mais vraiment avec mon
grand-père grand-mère tout ça qui
ramasse et une petite pièce par pièce
d'un petit mouchoir d'un coup une mouche
à tout ça comme tous les autres boîtes
qui on a senti monnaie pour avoir un
bout de terre c'est un terrain agricole
donc mais venez avec les données
amassées - j'ai ramassé kumo tout ça là
dessus et puis je n'ai relâche à ceux ci
venaient l'achat sont contentés un accès
la maman de gilbert elle a ouvert un
restaurant sur le terrain familial
depuis deux ans les pounia l'ont
rebaptisé zaza vous pouvez visiter coup
la grande salle abrite aujourd'hui tous
les souvenirs de la famille pounia la
photo du grand père les voyages en inde
les affiches de spectacles les amis de
toujours et les jours de gamme à toute
la famille est sur le pont passé mon le
papy des enfants c'est aussi celui qui
tient la caisse a pressé la basse et la
fille bas programmatrice du lieu c'est
un artiste qui crée la fille c'est maya
c'est elle qui a eu l'idée d'appeler ce
lieu zaza comme un à la malice qui
reflète bien le côté un peu fou du
projet un baiser hammami un baiser à
maman allez encore un et au travail
les numéros
ce numéro table et est apparemment non
même s'il est le leader d'un des groupes
emblématiques de la réunion même s'il
chante depuis 40 ans aux 1 gilbert
s'occupe lui-même de la technique métier
sayouba de les couteaux ils s'achètent
chine et la cuisine la cuisine fine
faire et l'atteinte chauffer au zinc en
ce moment la table une c'est la grande
table là on est d'accord
une centaine de personnes ont réservé ce
dimanche-là leur place au cabba repos
n'ya dans moins d'une heure ils seront
là
gilbert lui est maintenant passé en
cuisine et a revêtu la charlotte
réglementaire ouais
la musique est quelque chose qui fait
partie
[Musique]
chris higgins il est généralement senna
tente notamment de gilbert qui règne sur
la cuisine à 84 ans met un doigt cassé
l'empêchent d'être là aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est oui
en devenir ici elle m'a sali cote six
mois quand je fais
[Musique]
pour maya et gilbert chanteront devant
les spectateurs du sein
mais les poulains ne sont pas les seuls
à se produire dans la salle du
restaurant de grand bois
l'idée est d'accueillir ici des artistes
de tous horizons musique mais également
poésie danse théâtre de la réunion est
d'ailleurs bon alors c'est tout le monde
est prêt je vais faire entrer les gens
merci c'est gentil pendant que les
spectateurs prennent place derniers
préparatifs en cuisine c'est l'heure de
l'apéritif
le restaurant est maintenant plein et
voici à présent gilbert en salle pour
accueillir les uns et les autres connus
ou anonymes l'a dit monsieur la société
bonjour bienvenue dans cabaret tonia pas
paraître cause est pleine
[Musique]
c'est à vue ne regarde on va commencer
par des comptes l'a tout de suite et
nous mange un gazon quand même et puis
après ménard la musique a fait avec
quelques gâteaux ou la fée du gâteau
patate
oui
on a pensé que la vie puisse alors
patronne issing
dans la famille pounia je demande à
présent admis la conte
[Musique]
de tiko neydens reading
s'il reconnaît la vie c'est nicolas on
est quoi cela va aller comme les salades
oui c'est pas tout mais qui ici voilà un
au nadi faut travailler plus pour gagner
tu connais pas trop mais en tout cas
nous fait à rouiba nena le cousin qui
conserve
beaucoup d'imagés le joker on veut fait
déshéritant en salle et en cuisine
gilbert ahnee et maya n'arrête pas un
instant et quand tout le monde à bien
manger sans un moment de répit
maya mais l'ambiance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à chacun son tour maya achève son mini
concert elle va tenter de passer le
micro à gilbert avec toujours ce petit
jeu de la concurrence entre pays riches
mais sa maison et son frère oasis en
rajoute une couche bout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aux spectateurs du zares gilbert pounia
offre alors un duo inédit avec quesnel
[Musique]
non
puis maya le rejoint pour un final
endiablé
[Applaudissements]
c'était un après midi à zain à grand
bois avec la famille poulin
[Musique]
m